so now the first thing we need to do in
order to talk about code quality and
code cleanliness and like what matters
and what doesn't is we need to talk
about ideal code how do i define ideal
code now I borrowed my definition from
Sandi Metz who is a world-class Ruby
developer we learned this morning from
Laurie that most Ruby devs do not take
their language but I think that she did
she loves it and she is fantastic if I
could tell you one thing I would say go
find all of her talks listen to them
because they will make you a more
pragmatic empathetic reasonable
developer and so her her talk on design
she says in her book object-oriented
design a ruby the purpose of design is
allow you to design it later and its
primary goal is to reduce the cost of
change and the reason for that is is
that usually when we have the
responsibility of making something for a
customer something they've asked for or
something our stakeholders need they we
only have a partial lens into what that
thing will ultimately be but we have to
build it anyway and so if we optimize
our design for making hard decisions
later then that makes it easier to
change in the meantime as some of those
constraints become more apparent over
the weeks months and years and she broke
down a lot of tenants for me that I felt
that I held is immutable truths of good
quality code so the first one is dry and
the other speakers were kind of poking
fun at me because I have some visual
representations here now who has heard
the dry code is good it's like better
right yeah you don't want to repeat
yourself repeating yourself is bad so
she we were going through some code she
was like kind of like mentoring our team
and and m'as like giving us challenges
and we would like to give back examples
and then we had one that we were
particularly proud of because it was
like super dry it was awesome and she
said that look code looks so dry that it
chafes
what she meant by that was that wheel
all her that like dry coat is good but
there's a context in which it can be bad
and I want to show you that context
right now with some play-doh so right
here have some play-doh that is fresh
out of the jar and this play-doh is
moldable right it is not dry it is moist
maybe I don't know if I can cope with an
acronym for that but it's moldable we
can we we have this play-doh we can make
it whatever we want now on the other
side I have this play-doh that I left
out you can see I don't know if you can
see from there but it's a little it's a
little crusty and this is this is
effectively its final form it's not
going to change much from here so if I
squish it it doesn't change much if I
really press on it
it kind of crumbles it starts to break
at the edges now what do I do with all
this play-doh so it'll Ernst is that
there is a context for everything and
that a lot of times that line is things
that we know and things that we don't
know at least that's how I see it and
that's how we're gonna kind of talk
progress to this talk with those
boundaries so things that we know those
things definitely need to be stable like
you're not going to build a building out
of play-doh we want hard materials to
reinforce the things that we know to be
true and change very little but on the
other side we have a bunch of stuff that
we don't know a bunch of things that we
don't know about our customers things we
don't know about the space things that
we don't know about our team like our
team is growing like like 200% every
year so every day we have a new team
effectively and the problems that we get
into is when we take rules from one side
either side and try to adopt them in the
other so for example like stable long
lasting code should be dry it makes
sense that we don't we don't if we want
to make a change we want that to
propagate to the other parts of our code
base that are strong it's stable so
that's good
however if we try to put dry on the
pliable side things that we don't know
well then we end up with this we end up
always like constantly breaking things
this irritation of like having to Google
like do I use oil or water to rehydrate
this play-doh I still don't know the
best way I just buy new play-doh because
it's cheap and that's what we do a lot
we end up saying like this thing is
screwed we're just gonna have to rewrite
it now on the other side we have like
readability is extremely important for
code that churns a lot things that we
don't when we don't know clearly what
that code is gonna be like what the
final form of that code is however we
have code that is intentionally
unreadable we have code that has to be
performant that is its highest goal and
the fact that only a handful of
engineers are able to decipher it is
actually a feature it makes it that
thing needs to be stable and performant
and those are the highest goals of that
code and so when we try to apply
readability to that well then our
performance suffers so we need to be
careful about which like taking laws
from one side and trying to apply them
to the other so this is the part where I
tell you a story about a time I feel
felt stuck and my literally flipped
during this moment so we had a brand new
a brand new project that we were working
on it was kind of like a new login
screen for all of our apps I work on a
suite of applications it goes from we
have was it eight applications we needed
a new login chooser thingy you know so
you log in and they would ask you like
hey we're gonna log you into this app
but do you want to log into another app
instead and I was feeling very excited
because I'm a designer and we'd been
using react for about like three and a
half years at this point and I thought
man we've learned a lot I bet that when
I go into that codebase and like start
styling stuff like the code is just
gonna be awesome
like I'm gonna love working in that out
it's gonna be it's gonna be incredible
like we've learned so much there's been
so much crappy code that I've worked in
like this is just gonna be a delight it
was not so again in there first thing I
see is this so okay you need to style
the
login drop-down choose her and like okay
cool no problem so open up this file I
see okay so we've got a list with a list
item and then like a drop down menu in
it okay whatever I'll open up the first
thing I'll look at that out button I
open that up and I see okay so it's like
defined in this file it's used somewhere
else I guess I'll figure that out later
and this is the place I'm using it okay
cool I open it up like damn that's a lot
of code for like and that button but
whatever let's go let's go through this
so we have like you know a bunch of like
flow annotations at the top like that
was something new that everyone was like
super excited about when they started
okay cool whatever no big thing this is
the component definition and then this
is really the like four or five lines of
code that actually like do anything and
so I start looking at this thing and I'm
like okay so it's an anchor it's got
some classes applied I had an on click
and then it like has this like app name
is a problem you're thinking I'm like
I'm pretty sure that all of this like 50
lines of code does is like make this
button that is written as an anchor
inaccessible and do anything so I'm like
that sucks
so okay whatever let's just that let's
move on I open a app drop-down to see
what else is going on I see the kind of
same story it's defined and it's only
used in one other place great again flow
type annotations a bunch of stuff at the
beginning we have and then this is the
component definition and then this is
the bulk of the code and I start to
wonder something else like okay so as a
foreign developer I know like a little
bit about like HTML accessibility and
some like you know standard stuff and I
look at this and I see this div and its
anchor and his list I remember like oh
man it wasn't there like wasn't this
inside of like a list item and so I have
this list this honored list whoo list
item with app drop down which spits up
div with like other stuff inside of it
and I'm like really starting to get
pissed at this point because like I'm
going to have to
put together all this stuff I'm gonna
have to oil my play-doh just to be able
to style this stupid thing and my screen
looks like this at this point like what
the hell are you doing to me I was so
happy about jumping into your code and
so I just I changed to this and I was
feeling pretty good about myself I got
to like delete two-component files like
this is awesome this is like a you know
a better starting point for me but now I
have two test failures I'm like dude you
kidding me like I'm a designer I'm just
trying to like style this code like get
it you know get it to be using the right
elements and like now I have test
failures do I fix those do I throw it
back to you and make you fix them so
components are awesome but they also
suck because it merges everything
together and all of these like team
light all these lines that we've had
historically are a little bit blurred
and so the practices that you think are
best and whatever make it hard for me to
do my job now this this goes both ways I
know absolutely that I have made some
very strong enemies with the way that I
prefer to write CSS so I want to tell
you five like a handful of signs of
Deathly code where the ways that you can
think about code through this example so
the first thing that I think is like a
sign of code that is going to chafe you
it's speculation now this is the most
unholy yes lint creation that I think
exists today and this is the root cause
of why some of this code wisdom what's
hard to deal with now if you every time
I go into a file like I don't even like
because I work across the teams I don't
even look I just disabled this rule like
I have a key ski command for it like I
don't care if you have it or not it's
getting disabled so what it does is it
enforces that you only have one
component per file now the problem with
that is is that you have to name things
and we're notoriously bad at naming
things we're terrible at naming things
so it happens is he's making they're
making this log in chooser and then
they're like
okay well we have this thing and it
looks like a button and it has the app
name inside of it so we're gonna call
that app button now the problem with
this is that anytime you like kind of
hoist something up at the top and say
this is the app button life finds a way
other people are going to look at that
code and they're gonna try to be
responsible and be like has anyone ever
solved this problem before is there an
app button that I can use and like be
responsible with this codebase not
duplicate things because I've heard that
dry is awesome and important all the
time immutably so how can I can I can I
use this reuse this app button yep
that's good it's awesome except for this
app button sucks
we've determined this and so every time
it gets used that suck propagates
throughout the app and the suck gets
harder and harder and harder to remove
the more places that it is so so so
talking about that change that I made
we have the login chooser we have the
app drop-down we have an app button all
is like first-class files well that
sucks because like you know so we have
you know the that button file is defined
as its own the app drop-down file is to
find the zone and then we have this
login chooser that kind of imports both
of them and composes them together even
though all of this is just wrapped up to
support this one function or this one
feature so I ask that as you're working
through your code like one of the signs
is to make pure assumptions don't assume
that like you have made the perfect app
drop-down button unless you have other
cases where it's like oh this also
serves these things so look this is
pretty good bet that we're going to like
be serving our app well in the future
and stop naming things just stop if you
can if you can not name something do
that every time so in this case right
here I have I had these three files I
the the change that I made was I just
kind of pulled them in I deleted the app
button I just made that a a component in
the same file I didn't leave the app
drop-down made that a component missing
home file and then now the nullifier
looks like this I exported the thing
that
actually designed and like everything
has this kind of coherence like this app
button is not general-purpose it only
serves the thing that we've designed it
to serve now later on if we decide you
know what like you made a pretty classy
drop-down button like we want to export
it and see if this could be the one app
drop-down button or the app button for
app sorry I keep mixing these words this
is why naming things sucks because like
it's just so hard to like talk about
anything so so you can like just export
that in isolation see if it works you
can do the app button see if that works
and then ever if ever down the road
you're like you know what we're really
feeling confident that this thing is the
one I think we have a winner we got it
right the first time you can actually
explore like having an app drop down
file and then just like kind of
importing it from the place where it was
designed with a specific purpose and
then like export it as a prop down and
so you like you know what this is it
we're gonna stamp it so completion ism
is another thing that bothers me so I
want you to watch this kid who's seen
this gift before okay not everyone Oh
beautiful okay I'm gonna let you watch
it a few times I think this is actually
a come work like an ad for slim Samsung
TVs but I see it as like the perfect
illustration of why unit tests are a bad
idea so this guy just kind of waddles
around with a big flat-screen TV and
then leaves the stream to the TV it's
beautiful so now each of these
components we're kind of like kind of
again like kind of crystallized into
this form of like I think we got it
right and we have all of these interface
tests to make sure that they stay that
same way because damn it if we didn't
get it right the first time without
knowing any of the possible situations
where it might be used later so what
happened was when I deleted these files
well now I have these tests and I have
to delete these tests or just figure out
how to merge them into the login chooser
now that's a real pain in the ass
because like these tests are all like
they all
set up to like import that specific
thing test its unique interface instead
of testing it from the outside in
so I much prefer in these situations
where I have uncertainty I don't know
what the final form of this component or
feature is going to be to just test the
feature test at a high level whether
that be something where you actually
spin up a browser floor or something you
just do like an integration test on that
high level component like test the
feature and like let the implementation
change so if I mean in their style that
I shouldn't be breaking test by just
like applying a couple classes things
should be able to change should be able
to move around and like the test that a
user can click that button click the app
and get logged in should persist so this
is what my favorite quotes about tweets
about testing is outright tests not too
many
and mostly integration my rule for this
is to test as close to the customer as
possible there is a there's a sense of
like kind of completion ISM when you see
file without a test like oh you know and
I'm just gonna go in like write some
interface test for that like use type
scripting so nits are another place
where we start to see like code start to
crumble and I don't have a lot of a lot
of advice for this I have one thing it's
gonna be the one thing that actually
tell you you have to do formatting makes
everyone myopic you could write the best
pull request with the most for the most
thought through feature using the most
well-designed code of all time and if
you have a semicolon out of place or
like you accidentally used a tab instead
of like a couple spaces like that's the
feedback that you're gonna get so what
we do is in not all of our apps now but
we had started transitioning our apps to
prettier and who's heard of prettier
okay cool so about half of you prettier
is this amazing thing we're basically
you decide on a decide on a handful of
things rules that you want your
like code to be styled by but really
it's pretty opinionated out of the box
is going to give you a pretty standard
format do some likes things things for
you out of the box but it takes a lot of
these picky arguments about code out and
it's actually changed the way that a lot
of us think about code we think less
about code being like this thing that we
is like our art and like I'm applying my
style like to that my personal style to
this code and how lucky are you to have
someone that thinks about style as much
as I do and we think about it more like
like how the computer sees it which is
like the computer doesn't give half a
about how you style your code as
long as it works and this has allowed us
to write thinking more about the code
and knowing that it's going to knowing
that like in the pull request is going
to look right you can integrate this in
your editor or also is like a pre-commit
hook and the last thing when they share
with you today is this idea of noble
obstacles these totally get in the way
of our code so I wrote a book recently
called finish give yourself the gift of
done by Jon Acuff and he says noble
obstacle as a virtuous sounding reason
for not working toward a finish and this
is something that I feel all the time
and I imagine that you feel it too is
that if I commit code that I know has
some type of shortcoming that that
reflects on me that it reflects poorly
on my ability to kind of look into the
future and say you know what all of
these things are possible so I'm going
to like make it perform an out of the
box I need to do like X X Y & Z and so I
tend to compensate for that by just
being way too rigid and like doing way
more things than is necessary and I'm
hurting myself in the future I'm like
making decisions about the future that
might make it harder to change so what
I'm sort of doing is
I just add a comment into the code when
I do something that I feels like a
little bit dirty it's like this one I
just put debt date today I did a bad
thing p.m. said ship it with a link to
the Trello card now what this allows me
to do is I actually have a couple tests
in place where I will generate warnings
based on there being too many debt debt
comments in a file and so this helps me
identify like you know we've been like
really like kicking the can on this
thing for a really long time it's
possible that it's it's time that we
actually give this thing first-class
treatment I do the same thing with perf
it's like I don't know yet
how this thing's gonna get used how it's
going to get hammered but this is like
something that we should probably think
about I know that it may be a problem
but it's not a problem that we have
enough data yet to solve so we're gonna
kick the can down the road for a little
bit but I know about it this helps me
out dramatically thinking about like
when I'm making a pull request and
thinking like oh man it's just gonna
judge how like if I've been able to
predict the future well instead of just
solving the problem at hand what the
thing that our customers actually want I
mean - a really quick story we have so
we had sandy Mets out to train our
company on some some programming
techniques and tactics and she was
telling us about this a way to evaluate
code quality of code and whether it
needs to change as churn vs complexity
how often does the file change versus
how complex is it house how many kind of
decision tree is that it hasn't it
so um so that was like a really
interesting thing but she had this one
class that she was just totally enamored
by and she said to us she said this is
the dirtiest Ruby class I think I've
ever seen in my entire life it's
absolutely terrible and we're like
thanks
it's good to have you out what time's
our flight leave and but she was like
delighted by she's like but it's amazing
because this code never has to change
like this is very hardworking code it's
terrible but it just kind of like
continues to work just like it would not
make business sense for you to change
this code and all the effort would way
outweigh the reward and then I think two
years later a friend of mine met her up
at the conference and she didn't
remember us we did said oh yeah you know
like we had that quarter Darby file and
she was like yes I tell all my classes
about how terrible that class was she's
like I just said just like please tell
me you haven't changed it and that just
spoke volumes to me that her her
pragmatism allowed her to see beauty in
this terribly dirty code so why is this
hard for us this is very emotionally
hard for me I know that it's hard for
the rest of you to let go of some of
these things and like to trust other
people so why is this hard I think it
ties into who we are I think that we
have a fractured identity about what the
work that we do and what we're supposed
to be able to know and accomplish and I
think it has to do with what we believe
code is now the thing that I think is a
little bit broken is that we aren't
builders and this is kind of hard to
swallow because we have all of our
identities built up into these roles of
building we have developers we have
architects we use frameworks that have
scaffolding sometimes all of our work
uses these building analogies now I
think that's a great way to kind of
describe the process of writing code the
fact that everyone has a different role
and we come together to like to raise
something up and create something
however I don't think it adequately
describes the way that we feel every day
about working in a codebase and one of
the things that's strange is that a lot
of apps will outlive our
our dedication to it so you know the
apps that I work on now exist in five
years before I came to came to Planning
Center I have put five years and now but
they'll probably last until after I go
into retirement hopefully so we edit and
our work doesn't last I think what we do
we are farmers bump it up boom boom I
know you're thinking in and I think
we're farmers because we work on living
things code is much more like a living
thing than its structure that is like
built and planned and doesn't change
we're beholden to outside winds the
whims of our customers our stakeholders
our managers and buildings don't grow in
place and then slough off their dead
selves like an app does I think we
cultivate and we work together with our
code to be able to create something
that's going to serve us today tomorrow
and hopefully five years from now we're
working on code to make a product and we
work with our customers to make the
right product this partnership really
blew my mind the idea that I would
invest daily into this code and if I
wanted it to treat me well I had to
invest good things and do it and I had
to like think about me tomorrow our
customers and optimize for change
despite uncertainty without speculation
this is a very tight line that we're
walking sometimes so remember the goal
is to serve to share to adapt and make
that chedda
and change ain't always pretty so I'm
gonna leave you with no I'll leave you
with my favorite quote this is what we
we reference this Bible verse ironically
every time we're about to ship something
super dirty in our app so the Bible
verse goes like this
where there are no oxen the stable is
clean but abundant crops come by the
strength of the Ox
now proverbs are a little bit weird I
know and they're a little bit polite so
I'm gonna break this down for you clean
code is dead code they're where
money is made get it thanks so much for
listening
[Applause]